قبل ايام انتشر مقطع صادم على مواقع
التواصل في مصر للشاب وفتاه اثناء
ارتكابهما اعمالا منافيه للاداب على جسر
الساحه بالقاهره وفي وضع النهار الشرطه
تمكنت من ضبط مرتكبي الواقعه واحيل الى
النيابه العامه التي قررت بعد ذلك اخلاء
سبيليهما في كفاله ماليه بعد ان اقر
بممارسه الفعل حيث تربطهم علاقه عاطفيه
لكنهما قال ان المقطع يعود الى الابره
للماضي النيابه طلبت في بيان نشرتها عبر
الانترنت تحريات الشرطه حول الشخص القائم
على تصويره المقطع ونشره وترويجه عبر
مواقع التواصل ومعرفه اسباب تصوير المقطع
ان قسم الناس حول المقطع الفاضح فيما راى
البعض انا نشر الفيديو مهم لايقاف في
مشاهد مشابهه في المستقبل اخرون مع بيان
النيابه والقوام اللوم على مصور الواقعه
[موسيقى]
باعتقادكم ومن الناحيه القانونيه من يحكم
عليه المصور والناشر ام صاحب الفعل
قانونيه
المصري يعتبر من الافعال المنافيه للاداب
باعتباره فعل فاضح في الطريق العام والتي
يجرب فيها المشرع المصري ارتكاب مثل هذه
النوعيه من الجرائم لما فيها من اخلال
بالحياه والقيم واخلاق وعادات المجتمعات
العربيه انا يعني لا اتفق شكلا وموضوعا مع
محاوله القاء كل المسؤوليه على الشخص الذي
قام بالتصوير او بنشر هذا الفيديو يعني
خلينا نؤكد ان كثير من الجرائم التي
ارتكبت داخل المجتمع المصري على وجه
الخصوص خلال الفتره اللي فاتت لم يكشف
عنها الا وجود فيديوهات فتات المعادي
الطفله التي تم التحرش بها في المعادي لم
يكشف هذه الجريمه الا وجود فيديو تم نشر
وتداوله عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
والتي كان ثابته
الموضوعات تماما في الكشف عن الجريمه
فكره حبهما لبعضهم البعض لا يكترثان يعني
بعيدان لا يؤذيان اي احد هذا اذا كنت
تعتبره جريمه اخلاقيه او فضيحه فالمصور
سهم بنشر الفضيحه انا لا اعتبره جريمه
اخلاقيه القانون المصري هو الذي يعتبر
جريمه العديد من جرائم جرائم ال- ال- يعني
جرائم الجنس والجرائم المتعلقه بالاداب
العامه يتم تصويرها ويتم رصدها من خلال
الكاميرات التي ان تعلمي ان همم يعني همم
الغرور المصري الان بيتم تصوير كل
المخالفات التي تتم عبر الطرق والعديد من
المخالفات يعني متداول ومعروف في الشارع
ان تم التصوير بعض المشاهد لمخلفات في
المرور لافعال منافيه داخل السيارات هذا
هذا التصوير في حد ذاته وهمم ودفع الغرامه
الماليه عن هذه المخالفات كان سبب في
التوقف عن ارتكاب مثل هذه الافعال مره
اخرى الامن العقاب اساء الادب ونشوف الراي
الاخر مع من نيويورك مع المحامي احمد موسى
سيد احمد اهلا بك ما رايك بهذه الواقعه
وبالتصوير يعني يحاسب المصور المرتكبير
الفعل تفضل
الموضوع من الاول للاخر طبعا كل الاطراف
اخطات فيه الولد والبنت اخطاؤهم ما فيش اي
حد يقدر ان هو يقوله ان هم
ما فيش عندهم خطا لا عندهم خطا وخطا كبير
جدا المصور كمان عنده خطا وخطا كبير جدا
لان المصور هنا تساعد في انتشار الفيديو
وساعه انتشار الواقعه يعني النار كان
هشيمه كان يقدر بكل سهوله ان هو بعد ما
صور يقدم الفيديو للجهات المعنيه او
الشرطه للتخاذ اللازم لكن هو اللي هو عمله
ساعه 12 محتوى يكاد يكون اباحي نشره على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ساعد واهم قوه في نشر المحتوى هذا الولد
والبنت منعهم حتى من انهم يقدروا يدافعوا
عن نفسهم ده الرغم من الاخطاءهم بالرغم من
الخطا كبير جدا انا من وجهه نظر ان هو
اخطا خطا جاستين يستحق العقاب لانه
انتهك طبعا مش هاقول انتاج حرمه الحياه
الخاصه لان الفيديو اتصور في مكان عام
وطبعا خلاص هو صور ما صوروش في بيت
ماصورهوش في عربيه خاصه لكن احنا هنا
بنتكلم ان هو تصور بعض الاشخاص في طريق
عام ونشر المحتوى الذي يكاد يصنف امام
يعني ما
بعرف
فيديو انتشر بخلال الفعل لا هو صورهم من
قبل وقاعدين قبل ما يصير هالموضوع كانه
قعدوا قاصد يعني عن قصدته عمد دي حقيقه
وكمان هو عامل زوم بنسبه كبيره جدا على
الولد والبنت فهو متر لو احنا لو احنا كنا
نكافه امتى لو هو ترسل لهم عشان يقول
الصدقاءهم او يرفض اخطاءهم وقدم الفيديو
للجهاتنيه ساعتها احنا كنا نسقف له ونقول
له بربوا عليه كده انت هنا ساعات ان انت
تمنع ان الجريمه دي تحصل مره ثانيه لان هي
هتقبض عليهم
[موسيقى]